bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique l'émission
consacrée aux coulisses de la
mondialisation du bio oui mais du bio
européen et bien c'est le combat que
même mon invité claude gruffat et député
vert européen ancien président de la
coopérative biocoop il milite pour que
l'europe produisent plus de produits bio
et en importe - bonjour claude gruffat
bonjour alors la commission européenne
est assez engagé sur le fait qu' on
puisse en europe produire plus de bio
est-ce que c'est suffisant ou pas
d'après vous
c'est pas suffisant puisque on importe
en europe des produits bio à hauteur de
près de 3 milliards par an donc c'est
déjà un chiffre là il ya une nouvelle
réglementation qui rentre en vigueur en
2022 et à ce titre là la commission a
commandé au parlement un plan bio pour
réajuster un certain nombre de points
pour permettre de développer plus la
production bio en europe dans ce plan il
avait trois axes le premier c'est
précisément le développement de
l'agriculture biologique c'est à dire
plus de surfaces en bio en europe on a
une stratégie qui était dans ce qu'on
appelle le green deal alors c'est des
gros mots pour le commun d'entre nous
mais ça veut dire une stratégie pour
qu'on ait plus de verre en europe et là
dedans il ya farm to fork de la ferme à
la table qui dit ferme avant tout la
ferme à la fourchette banon qui dit 25 %
de bio en europe en 2030 harry
l'objectif oui ça c'est l'objectif de la
commission on est d'accord ça c'est
l'objectif je suis pas sûr que ce soit
l'objectif du parlement alors quand le
plan bio ont été demandés effectivement
s'est bagarré pour que dans le monde
nous les verts entre autres on s'est
bagarré pour que au plan européen cet
objectif de 25% soit porté dans le plan
bio et il n'a pas été votée les
conservateurs ont refusé de le mettre
franchement sur le devant de la scène en
disant c'est un objectif puissants
jusqu'à 2030 alors aujourd'hui à l'heure
actuelle les terres consacrées au bio en
europe c'est je crois
8 % 8 % à surfaces agricoles européennes
en france c'est 9% well les deux bornes
en autriche ces 26 % à eux des pailles
en eux dépassent pas ceux qui ont pris
un engagement déjà depuis longtemps on
fait ainsi donc bien une volonté
politique et une irlande c'est 2% donc
d'abord ne basse des pays européens sur
l'engagement à aller sur d'agriculture
violer ce qui se passe est ce que les
parlementaires qui sont pas pour 7 25%
d'ici 2030 pense que la solution se
trouve dans le marché où ils ont pas
envie de faire ce geste supplémentaire
il pense que le modèle de l'agriculture
biologique ne peut pas nourrir le monde
c'est une idée qui se véhicule par
l'agriculture conventionnelle depuis 40
ans fait en dix ans il n'y a que le
productivisme et l'agriculture
productiviste qui peut nourrir le monde
qui peut penser qu'avec 12 % des
surfaces agricoles du monde ce qui est
la surface agricole de l'europe 12% du
monde en fait c'est 12% peuvent nourrir
le monde c'est pas possible
mécaniquement ce n'est pas possible
aujourd'hui ces surfaces pour prendre un
exemple en céréales produisent 80
quintaux de l'hectare les plus pointues
produit 120 quintaux de l'ectaa mais
pour pouvoir produire pour le monde il
faudrait produire 600 ou 800 quintaux de
l'état ce qui n'existe pas donc c'était
un concept qu'il ne fonctionne pas sur
le long terme alors pour autant ces
pays-là pense que le marché devrait être
suffisant c'est à dire qu'on peut
pourquoi pas importer les produits bio
en dehors de l'ue alors on peut importer
des produits bureau dehors de lieux la
question que ça pose c'est la même qui
se pose cruellement aujourd'hui avec la
guerre de l'ukraine c'est la
souveraineté alimentaire c'est à dire
qu'à un moment donné si on produit soit
même les matières premières pour se
nourrir on est à peu près sûr d'être
nourris si on les importent et qui plus
est sont les importe de loin cette
sécurité tombe et après c'est le cas ce
qui concerne notre bio on la porte de
loin puisqu'il semble que l'ukraine
était un des principal partenaire de
l'europe sur le bio est un gros
partenaire sur l'europe sur le but on
met en ordre importe des produits
alimentaires n'importe pas que des
sérères nous importent des fruits on
importe des légumes on importe tout un
tas de choses et là ça peut venir
d'egypte ça peut venir de chine ça peut
venir d'amérique du sud on a les kiwis
qui viennent ne vous nouvelle zélande
par exemple oui ça vient de toutes les
parties du monde deguire oui on en
produit en espagne et en france donc
cela pourrait très bien se dit que votre
politique vos propositions c'est la
souveraineté alimentaire c'est moi le
marché moi ça me paraît fondamental et
quand c'est le marché qui guident et
qu'on a une crise qui nous pèse dans les
doigts comme la crise de la guerre
ukrainien en europe en ce moment on voit
bien que la disponibilité des matières
premières alimentaires est un vrai sujet
depuis ce arrêt des exportations de la
part de la russie et de l'ukraine par la
force des choses et on voit le prix des
céréales qui flambent et puis on voit de
l'autre bout de la planète l'inde qui
arrête aussi ses exportations depuis
quelques jours et du coup pareil ça fait
encore une surenchère sur les prix etc
et du coup ben forcément c'est les plus
pauvres qui payent l'addition là parce
que c'est ce qu'ils vont qui vont être
les plus sombres et shark c'est que en
ces périodes tendues un petit plus
étendue par un changement climatique et
qu'on ressent très clairement avec la
sécheresse c'est pas le bio qui va
sauver le monde c'est le productivisme
c'est ce qu'on vous dit ça c'est ce
qu'on dit c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure que ça continue d'être la
croyance des conservateurs et de
l'agriculture conventionnelle mais en
réalité les de plus en plus exposés
parce que les engrais chimiques qu'ils
utilisent sont faits avec le gaz
ukrainien elle pétrole russes et
ukrainiens et du coup ils sont aussi
pris dans les mailles du filet de manque
de souveraineté par rapport aux matières
ou aux intrants ont fait ça dure aux
produits qu'on utilise pour faire
pousser les les céréales et qui
deviennent de plus en plus cher et
qu'ils deviennent inabordables des
agriculteurs qui arrête de mettre des
anglais parce que ils peuvent tout
simplement plus les payer du ceta
devient une aberration économique qui
sont les
les gens qui représentent les freins au
bio est ce que sont les industriels les
agro industriel ou pas abbott clairement
c'est l'agro industrie qui vit de la
chimie aujourd'hui qui est le frein
principal au développement de
l'agriculture biologique leur modèle est
basé sur la vente des produits chimiques
que soient les pesticides ou tu vois les
uns et chimiques c'est eux qui ont
empêché le parlement de voter l'objectif
final sur 100 fait pression et du
lobbying sur certains parlementaires
pour empêcher le développement de
l'agriculture biologique un rythme plus
soutenu à savoir avec l'objectif de 25
pour son bien sûr bon alors il ya une
difficulté au niveau européen où on a
dit que la france aussi était un neuf et
demi pour cent sur ses terres consacrées
au bio dont il ya un effort à faire en
français ce qui les fait cet effort
manifestement il n'ya pas la volonté
politique puisque dans le plan
stratégique national qui découle de la
politique agricole commune récemment
votée il était demandé aux états de
faire un effort particulier sur la
question du développement de la lecture
biologique la france donc l'europe à 10
25 % en 2030 la france a dit 18% en 2027
et 20 % en 2030 donc déjà là pas fixé le
même objectif donc on voit déjà la
réticence à vraiment soutenir
l'agriculture biologique en france à tel
point que le la commission a refusé le
pala rigide français eut égard à son
manque d'ambition sur le développement
de l'agriculture biologique par rapport
aux objectifs européens comment vous
expliquez que l'autriche soit si fort là
dessus
il ya tout un tas de facteurs et je
pense que naturellement l'autriche est
un pays montagneux est un pays où
l'agriculture traditionnelle est encore
là encore une forte empreinte dans la
culture agricole du pays ce qui a donc
permis de développer plus facilement une
agriculture qui correspond à savoir
l'agriculture biologique
l'agroforesterie tous tous les systèmes
agronomique qui respectent plus
l'environnement et qui respecte plus la
terre la fertilité des terres tout ce
qui fait le bien-être animal tout ce qui
fait l'essence même de deux des règles
agronomique de la nourriture biologique
donc il était plus proche au départ donc
peut-être que le pas été moins difficile
à passer et peut-être qu'ils sont aussi
moins atteints par la glace chimique
elle fait atteint la france ou d'autres
pays européens est ce que c'est le bon
chiffre 50 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires du bio par an en europe
on est d'accord on a fait ça en 2021 oui
c'était le chiffre d'affaires de la bio
mais nos importations serait de 2 ou 3
milliards c'est pas beaucoup en fin de
compte dans le mix général oui mais
c'est alors on mais mathématiquement sur
le papier ce rebond peut dire c'est pas
beaucoup mais ça représente quand même
énormément de surface qui pourraient
être produites en europe donc du coup
pourquoi importés c'est à dire affaiblir
notre balance commerciale quand on peut
produire sur le sol européen des taxes
par mois fait les sionistes à ce moment
là
en l'exemple de la france en france on
produit 70% des produits bio qu'on peut
produire enfants sur les produits en
france 30% soit importé pour les 70% on
ne taxe pas de protectionnisme on peut
faire le pas supplémentaire des 30 et on
n'est pas protectionniste juste au
produit ce dont on a besoin et il y aura
près il après on apportera des choses on
apportant des bananes bio
mais on apportera des débats tous les
produits agrumes on apportera du café on
apportera du sucre on apportera kg on va
pas arrêter les importations bio juste
produisons ici qu'on est capable de
produire ici et puis les importations ça
sera ce qui appartient en production
reste du monde souveraineté alimentaire
l'impact sur l'emploi du bio géant si on
peut le mettre en avant c'est surtout
que l'agriculture biologique est
fortement utilisatrices d'emploi
2,5 fois plus que l'agriculture
conventionnelle
donc c'est un vrai un vrai sujet pour
l'emploi et puis si on dit que les
produits bio de proximité on les fait
qu'en france aujourd'hui on a une
demande de produits bio de proximité les
magasins spécialisés bio la grande
distribution qui à la cantine quelle
mère ne veut pas mettre du bio et local
à la cantine n'y a pas d'offre madoff
moi j'avais calculé qu'il faut installer
au moins soixante mille paysans bio de
proximité pour répondre à cette demande
si 60 mm l'envisagera bien comment qui
vivent à bien ses soixante mille mais il
est vrai bien il ya la demande mais y'a
pas l'offre
après aujourd'hui un prêt à tout jamais
un moment nous dit oui le la bio la
consommation de la bio plafonne ou
baissent c'est surtout l'offre qui n'est
pas présente qui est responsable de ça
si cette offre existait il y aurait
beaucoup plus de bio à la cantine si
elle était structuré si elles étaient
construites il était soutenu par des
politiques publiques on aurait beaucoup
plus de bio locale présente sur le
marché français bien une dernière
question le prix toujours un problème
d'accès au bio alors l'accès au bio
c'est vrai que de produire bio coûtent
un peu plus cher il ya un manque de
soutien aujourd'hui la politique
agricole commune avec un budget pour la
france 2 14 milliards d'euros 1,9 qui
viennent de l'europe le reste vient de
la france 14 milliards d'euros pour
soutenir l'agriculture conventionnelle
500 millions pour soutenir l'agriculture
biologique donc si on soutenait
réellement on aurait un développement 2
ce développement ont critiqué si on
avait en france aujourd'hui si on
augmentait de 15 % la consommation de
produits bio 10 15% on baisserait d'au
moins 15 % les prix parce qu'on ferait
des économies d'échelle sur les coûts
intermédiaires qui n'enlève rien au prix
d'achat au producteur qui n'ajoute rien
dans l'assiette du consommateur juste
ont compris une décharge intermédiaire
aujourd'hui inutile parce que le niveau
de volume est trop bas et là on paie
serait déjà de 15% bris de scellé car tu
pris avec le conventionnel aujourd'hui
une merci beaucoup claude gruffat pour
vos réponses l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique est terminée
évidemment vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission sur france 24 points comme sur
nos réseaux sociaux et nos podcasts à
revoir
[Musique]